[Music]
in air instrument news oh I know it's a
bitter bite Josh from Wong foo know
they're talking about our Josh and Wong
foo oh like Wang Fu's gonna steal our
Josh away okay you could take them
because I want Ted let's start treating
fate of empress ted has an NSX and we
drive together
ooh the treadle burner yeah West has a
has a evil and it's like really road
racing but like it's not a two-seater
it's a four-seater a young boy was
forced to pretend perform in his music
which title after forgetting his
instrument is this video that's [ __ ]
hilarious I love this [ __ ] I've seen it
is this like an Asian [ __ ] oh really
I want to see it's pretty it's like the
dark Asians it's pretty Asian it is it's
technically I feel like some Asian
punishment those you saw get it doesn't
matter you still have to perform that's
like a regular parent ripped like honey
next time just remember your instrument
so if it's Asian is that you've been
practicing this whole time I don't give
a [ __ ] up their [ __ ] when all the
schoolgirl panties I feel like my
parents might really do something
similar it is like your skin like
remembers coming back up you yeah all
right can we see what it is no oh so
this takes place in Saratoga so that's a
movie oh I like yeah Saratoga is a very
affluent area area Saratoga very nice
there my little experiment so we got it
I know thank you so this is Ashna and
Abbott a smart and avid know about safe
mother sister and too young for you very
very ha ha that's a good-looking family
though that's a hairy little brother in
between them
log uh so she tweeted this out so my
brother left his recorder and the
teacher still made him before oh yeah
yes
here we go
[Music]
yawning Indian Chinese yeah that's cool
is this pictures but at the end no I
think he's very flexible look it's all
Indian and Chinese kids no and so that
went viral
and here I'm going to show you guys some
reactions on Twitter
this one says well you can sound bad it
doesn't sound bad next to an music
teachers are either both loving little
parent types or heartless leaders there
are no in-betweens so which one is this
teacher both so answers I got a mixed
mixed reaction here because half of the
people are thinking this is so funny
this is hilarious it's cool it teaches
him to be responsible exactly I like
that yeah and there's the other half
where it's like that's so [ __ ] up so
like I provide it's so humiliating for
that kid and that's the point it's
supposed to be humiliating right exactly
should be [ __ ] sick here you have
your recording here's a dildo play this
without you billion as you know the age
I will be crying I don't want to put up
a map and I just use it this morning
yeah the next one says teachers
accountability responsibility of his
teachers yeah okay action I agree and in
this one he secured the teachers wrong
for putting him up in front shot ah
what's he's she trying to embarrass him
tell him he walked out or maybe that's
just his usual spot maybe there's no
specific area the teachers Hanako
that's if people read into the situation
like PCs third from the right
keep it down
I know area insists employment air
recorder thought of you wanted in the
world he was actually hitting the
buttons ol1 handled the other high was
like so far away he was advanced race it
was acutely on yawning on stage he did
not feel any sort of embarrassment so
the other half of you guys just show up
it didn't affect him one bit
you know the one says at least your
brother knows which notes he should play
instead of just standing there doing
nothing
the teacher is wrong for embarrassing oh
you are such a [ __ ] put that was my
kid I'd be like thank you teacher
because it's his dumbass fault I told
him to remember it's his fault now he
needs to learn that you can't just [ __ ]
around if you have a responsibility and
a duty you have to complete it see this
person when you have kids your kid's
gonna be a little push yeah hmm next one
this one says I'm dying why is he in the
front and then the sister replies the
teacher hates him so that's coming from
the sister maybe a joke next one I
choose to believe that the brother
actually gave his record to another
child that he lost his he has another
person making up their own story yeah I
mean considering a positive light though
true but then the sisters replies thing
he didn't lol he just lost it but I'm
thinking he actually broke it and lied
to me and his teacher there you go
that's why she has one of those reality
check sisters no actually he is not he
is clumsy alot that [ __ ] yeah and then
there was just a lot of it was mainly a
lot of people angry about this because
of the really embarrassment factor thing
looking first at all he didn't give him
[ __ ] man that's why he needed the
pleasure it could be clearly gonna give
a [ __ ] yeah he was yawning was
scratching and picking his nose
took you Thanks I thought he was like
doing a really big note at the end yeah
yeah yeah and this is transit saying
after that performance ever definitely
doesn't want to pursue music so this
whole is biased by the way one of the
dogged Indian kids never seen in my life
slight thought he was black for singing
in the business I remember when my
nephew was gonna do his Christmas choir
Playa Playa go and he was like he would
perform it he would get it ready he's
like I know the song he's like loud he's
singing it to all of us and so we all go
and he goes on stage right he's wearing
this like little angel outfit and he has
this like star honest and then they made
like a big paper star like him it's tied
to his forehead and all that so they go
up and as soon as they start singing he
gets stage fright right on should you
see this like five year old boy just
standing there with his mouth wide open
and just staring from left to right and
then the star thing just Falls and
covers his face and all you see is these
little [ __ ] lips just dangling right
there and then he's just looking left
and right and the whole song is done and
he doesn't even fix this thing an adult
comes up and moves it up and then they
walk offstage all of it clapping you
know there's like one kid that's
performing his ass off like yeah and
then there's another kid that's like
kind of singing and swinging back and
forth and like looking off and it was
the best thing ever
because of the level of confidence that
he had he was like I'm gonna do this
show I'm gonna sing it and then when he
got there he just froze up was the Trish
thing yes
good name always made you do that [ __ ]
at church it was it was a Christian
school or a church thing yeah I was one
of those do we had a sing [ __ ] silent
night and mind you like I was at the age
of like 13 I'm coming I'm like the same
size I am now so basically an all-boys
quiet background huh basically I look
like a rapist that infiltrated up we'll
all Boys Choir like this giant you know
I'm so weird cuz now yours giant with
like a big baby face I'd looked exactly
the same at age 13 I do now I understand
that just I look so out of place there's
like a video recording somewhere all the
kids that like your hips eyes and [ __ ]
yeah oh [ __ ] was this was a rapist in
the bag dude trying to pretend like you
too childish it's like I'm [ __ ] manic
adore you guys whenever you had to
performance I love perform I love
performing to you I would get nervous
that I would never freaked out Oh Shania
I remember during this green belt coming
food test so that like one of these
tournaments where you do like forms
performance and I was practicing like my
ass off and I wanted to kill it and I
remembered halfway through the form I
[ __ ] forgot it so I just started keep
doing what I what the last three blues
were know and then like I just I froze
up and there's like a roll of like 10
black belts that are there to give you
numbers right and I'm like I look at
them I look at the cloud and then I see
my mom in the corner and I'm like [ __ ]
that was like one of the most
embarrassed times I ever did I just I
was like in this dance right this way
thank you I just walked off guys
remember ballin my idol [ __ ] up on
salsa and then the next time I had
another like tournament I practiced my
ass off like non-stop over and over and
over and over and the whole time I think
I was so traumatized from the first
times that the whole time I was doing
the form like every move in my mind I
was like don't forget don't like don't
forget and I end up wait first here's
the good the embarrassment drove you to
practice harder was so [ __ ] scared
did you get in trouble though after you
got you [ __ ] up the first one my mom
was like I think she saw how embarrassed
I was so for the first time she didn't
kick my ass but thereafter she thought
after she saw me calm down she's like
see you practiced a hundred times you
didn't get it and I have to practice
about not
your mom's extreme dude God cheese
probably but it works though it's
literally you have to become a part of
your body you can't forget it you gotta
make it part of our body
I was like that kid that was two and
stares like I felt like it wasn't cool
to be on stage
and like a really young age as well all
the booths it's like oh I feel so weird
like this isn't cool I'm not being cool
I don't know so did you do show-and-tell
stuff everyone ever did was show nah
mean I was like I couldn't wait for
show-and-tell like yeah bitchin they're
not going to know what they see yeah I
got a [ __ ] plastic knife for
show-and-tell you got is trouble oh my
god deep is a Rambo knife and everyone's
like why didn't the princess of food hmm
I was always super super shy and
embarrassed like that's why it took me
years to get over my camera shame since
it's like I couldn't do it now I've
always I would even put on my own little
place at home like you know judge so
sweetie sweetie me as a kid kids are
free come on
my mom would have her friends come over
for karaoke and they would get the
lights and they have like you know my
dad's house does that giant like yeah
like high five [ __ ] stereo system as
soon as they start seeing these Chinese
folk songs I will start like coming in
yeah and I'll start dancing with the
music of a stalker beautiful [ __ ] and
you think like you're like this you're
just like the main actor of the whole
show huh dude I got into my mom's makeup
and like I did clown makeup I hit all
kinds of [ __ ] I couldn't wait and on top
of that since my parents were teaching
music all the time and we had like
recitals every year I think it was like
three times a year or something like
that so we always had these different I
guess concert halls or auditoriums or
small places that they would rent to
have friends and family watch all their
students perform and after a certain
time I stopped taking lessons and I told
my parents I don't want to do it anymore
but I perform at all the performances so
I would just learn stuff and then like I
would memorize the songs and then
every time I go I'm going to perform and
there's some times that I don't know the
song full way so I will collab with my
dad and I would just do the parts that I
do know and you would do the other part
so that [ __ ] was really fun hey you guys
want to stock any of us we'll go ahead
down to the description box below and
you can follow us on Instagram and all
kinds of stuff for more videos
[Music]